IT’S HIS THIRD TRIP TO THE
BORDER.
BRIAN, AINSLEY, STEVE?
STEVE: ALL RIGHT, GRIFF.
A LOT OF MOVING PART TO THIS
STORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET’S BRING AN EXPERT ON THIS
TOM HOMAN FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
AND ACTING ICE DIRECTOR.
TOM, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: RIGHT THERE AT THE END,
GRIFF SHOWED THAT TWEET THAT
KAMALA HARRIS PUT OUT WHERE SHE
SAID SHE SPOKE TO THE MEXICAN
PRESIDENT OBSERVE OBSERVE OBRADO
HIM.
IS MEXICO COOPERATING?
WOULDN’T THEY BE STOPPING THESE
PEOPLE FROM COMING INTO OUR
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
MEXICO IS NOT COOPERATING AT THE
LEVEL THEY DID WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
WITH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
THEY HAD AN AGREEMENT.
ALSO HAD AN AGREEMENT WITH ALL
THREE CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES.
THE FIRST THING JOE BIDEN DID
WAS KILL THOSE YEEMENTS.
MEXICO DID MORE CONTROLLING THE
SOUTHERN AND NORTHERN BORDER.
THEY WELCOMED THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO PROGRAM.
ALL OF THAT WAS DONE AWAY BY JOE
BIDEN IN TWO DAYS.
MEXICO IS NOT COOPERATING WITH
THIS COUNTRY THE WAY IT SHOULD
BE.
AINSLEY: TOM, WE KEEP SEEING
IMAGES OF ALL THESE KIDS THE
LATEST THIS MORNING IS THE 5 AND
6-YEAR-OLD SIBLINGS THAT WERE
ABANDONED PUT OVER THE BOULDER
ROCKS ON THE SIDE OF OUR COUNTRY
AND HAD THEIR MOM’S PHONE NUMBER
AND NAMES WRITTEN ON HEIR ARM
AND A NOTE.
WE HEARD GRIFF TALK ABOUT THE
MS-13 GANG MEMBER SAW THOSE
OTHER KIDS DROPPED OVER THE GATE
A FEW DAYS AGO.
THE YEMEN TERRORIST SUSPECTS.
THEN WE ARE LEARNING THIS
MORNING SAN ANTONIO, THE
GOVERNOR, GOVERNOR ABBOTT WANTS
TO SHUT DOWN THE FACILITY THAT’S
HOUSING CHILDREN BECAUSE OF
REPORTS OF SEXUAL ABUSE.
FAMILY AND PROTECTIVE SERVICES
SAYS THAT THEY CAN CONFIRM THREE
SEPARATE REPORTS OF ABUSE.
HERE’S THE GOVERNOR.
WE WILL GET YOUR REACTION ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> THESE PROBLEMS ARE A BUY
BYPRODUCT OF HIND’S OPEN BORDER
POLICIES.
THIS FACILITY IS A HEALTH AND
SAFETY NIGHTMARE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
PRESIDING OVER THE ABUSE OF
CHILDRENCHILDREN.
TO END THIS ABUSE, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MUST IMMEDIATELY
SHUT DOWN THIS FACILITY.
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE IN THIS
FACILITY SHOULD BE MOVED TO
OTHER FEDERALLY RUN FACILITIES
WHERE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
THE SPACE, PERSONNEL AND
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THEIR
SAFETY.
AINSLEY: TOM, YOUR REACTION?
>> THE GOVERNOR IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
BECAUSE HERE IS WHAT NO ONE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S
CONTRACT WITH NGOs WHO HAVE NO
BUSINESS RUNNING DETENTION
FACILITIES.
"THE WASHINGTON EXAMINER" BROKE
A STORY LAST NIGHT ABOUT THE WAY
THEE CONTRACTS ARE BEING LET.
WE HAVE FAMILY RESIDENTIAL
CENTERS THAT ARE LICENSED.
THAT ARE RUN BY CONTRACTORS WHO
WORK THROUGH ICE WHO HAVE
PEDIATRICIANS ON SITE, SOCIAL
WORKERS ON SITE, CHILD
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
THESE WERE BUILT FOR VULNERABLE
PEOPLE, WOMEN AND CHIRP.
AND THEY ARE PRACTICALLY EMPTY
BECAUSE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CALLS THEM FOR-PROFIT PRISONS.
SO THEY WOULD RATHER WALK AWAY
FROM THE STATE OF THE ART
FACILITY, THE GOLD STANDARD FOR
VULNERABLE PEOPLE.
THEY WALK AWAY FROM THESE
FACILITIES, LEAVE THEM HALF
EMPTY AND SIGNING CONTRACTS WITH
FEDERAL NGOs?
THE PERSON AT ICE AHEAD OF NOW
CONTRACT DETENTION BEDS KAREN
McNULTY NGO AND ADVOCATE SHE
IS MAKING THE FINAL DECISION ALL
DETENTION CONTRACTS OVER AND
ABOVE THE EXPERIENCED OFFICERS
WHO ACTUALLY RUN DETENTION
FACILITIES WHO ACTUALLY
CONTRACTED WITH DETENTION
FACILITIES FOR DECADE, SHE IS
MAKING THE DECISION AND
WASHINGTON EXAMINER JUST BROKE A
STORY THAT SOME OF THESE
CONTRACT ARE BEING AWARDED TO
PEOPLE WHO WORKED THE BIDEN
TRANSITION TEAM AND BIDEN
CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE GOING TO COMPANIES LIKE
THE ENDEAVOR $86 MILLION FOR
HOTEL ROOMS?
THAT’S 77,000 PER ALIEN WHEN WE
HAVE FAMILY RESIDENTIAL CENTERS
WHO WERE BUILT FOR THE VERY SAME
REASON TAKING CARE OF THESE
CHILDREN.
IT’S RIDICULOUS THE -- IF ANY
CONGRESSMAN OR SENATOR IS
WATCHING THIS SHOW, I IMPLORE
THEM TO DO A CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION HOW THESE
CONTRACTS ARE BEING AWARDED TO
THESE OPEN BORDER ADVOCATES WHO
HAVE NO BUSINESS RUNNING THESE
KIND OF FACILITIES.
BRIAN: THAT’S WHY TEXAS IS
SUING.
THEY HAVE GOT TO BE GIVEN HEADS
UP IT’S HAPPENING ON THEIR
PROPERTY AND THEIR LAND.
DON’T WORRY, TOM, YOU ARE
OVERREACTING.
ALL THOSE REPORTS AND MINORS
CRYING ALONE WITHOUT PARENTS,
THAT’S NO BIG DEAL BECAUSE
SPEAKER PELOSI SAYS JOE BIDEN
HAS GOT THIS.
LISTEN.
>> THE FACT IS THAT WE’RE ON A
GOOD PATH AT THE BORDER UNDER
LEADERSHIP OF JOE
BIDEN-PRESIDENT BIDEN.
WE WERE IN A VERY BAD SITUATION
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
BRIAN: IF YOU ZOOMED IN YOU
COULD HAVE SEEN HER LAUGHED
MAYBE IN THE BACKGROUND?
IS SHE KIDDING?
IS ANYONE BUYING THAT?
>> LOOK, NANCY PELOSI ISN’T
SMART AT ALL.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
SHE IS PROBABLY THE LEAST SMART
CONGRESSWOMAN TO EVER BE A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS CHILDREN ARE
DYING.
CHILDREN ARE BEING ABANDONED.
31% OF WOMEN ARE BEING RAPED.
CARTELS ARE MAKING MILLION.
LAST MARCH 33,000 APPREHENSIONS
THIS MARCH 171,000.
IT IS NOT UNDER CONTROL.
IT’S A MESS, CHAOS BUILT BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
AND THIS WAS BY DESIGN.
THIS ISN’T BY ACCIDENT.
THIS ISN’T MISMANAGEMENT.
THIS IS OPEN BORDERS.
THIS IS WHAT JOE BIDEN SOLD OUT.
BRIAN: THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS
TOLD HEY, DO YOU.
THIS JUST LIKE VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE WOULD SAY HEY, HANDLE THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
SHE WAS GIVEN THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOW WHAT SHE CAN DO AND HAS
SHOWN THAT SHE DOESN’T WANT TO
DO ANYTHING.
SHE HAS MADE ONE PHONE CALL TO
MEXICO.
SHE HAS NOT VISITED THE BORDER.
SHE HAS BEEN TO CONNECTICUT ON
MARCH 26TH.
WHY NOT?
ON THE 27TH TO 31st BACK IN
WASHINGTON.
THEN TO BRENTWOOD, CALIFORNIA TO
VISIT HER OLD STOMPING GROUNDS.
OVER TO OAKLAND AND THEN TO
CHICAGO TO TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IS THAT SOMEBODY WHO WANTS TO
TACKLE A PROGRAM -- A PROBLEM?
>> I HAVE A DIFFERENT OPINION.
I DON’T WANT HER ANYWHERE NEAR
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE SHE WILL MAKE
IT WORSE.
LOOK, THEY DON’T WANT TO FIX
THIS PROBLEM.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT THEY’RE
TRYING TO FIX.
MARK MY WORD THIS IS HAPPENING.
THEY WANT TO GET REALLY GOOD AT
RELEASING PEOPLE AS FAST AS THEY
CAN SO THERE IS NO OVERCROWDING.
THEY WILL IGNORE THE NUMBERS.
THEY WILL IGNORE THE THOUSANDS A
DAY.
WILL.
BRIAN: THAT’S WHY TEXAS IS SUING
THEM.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND THEY SHOULD BE SUING THEM.
AND MORE STATES NEED TO SUE
THEM.
THIS ADMINISTRATION HALLS NO
INTENTION OF SECURING THIS
BORDER.
THEY HAVE NO INTENTION OF
ENFORCING IMMIGRATION LAWS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE MADE THAT CLEAR.
THEY CREATED THIS CRISIS AND
THEY GET REALLY GOOD AT
RELEASING PEOPLE SO THERE IS NO
OVERCROWDING.
STEVE: ALSO GETTING REALLY GOOD
AT MAKING SURE NOBODY WHO WORKS
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TELLS
THE PRESS ABOUT WHAT’S GOING ON.
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE DAYS AGO WE
HEARD THAT THOSE TWO YEMENI GUYS
WERE STOPPED AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
ONE OF THEM HAD A SIM CARD IN
THERE.
THEY WERE ON THE TERRORIST WATCH
LIST.
AND THEN THEY TOOK COUNSEL THE
PRESS RELEASE SO THAT PEOPLE
WOULDN’T KNOW THE DETAILS
BECAUSE OF NATIONAL SECURITY,
TOM.
AND THIS ON THE HEELS OF THE
FACT THAT REPUBLICANS WERE ABLE
TO PRESSURE THE CBP TO ADMIT
THAT SINCE OCTOBER FOUR OTHER
PEOPLE ON THE TERRORIST WATCH
LIST HAVE BEEN APPREHENDED.
THREE OTHER YEMENESE AND A
SERBIAN.
THAT MAKES SIX THAT WE KNOW OF.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE ONLY WAY THAT
THEY CAN GO AHEAD AND CONTINUE
THIS RIDICULOUS, IT’S NOT A
CRISIS PEOPLE IS THROUGH
CENSORSHIP.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING I
TALKED TO SEVERAL PEOPLE IN
COMMAND OF CBP.
I WON’T MENTION THEIR NAMES
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE IN A LOT OF
TROUBLE.
THAT PRESS RELEASE WAS TAKEN
DOWN BECAUSE IT WAS BAD PRESS
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION.
STEVE: EXACTLY.
>> THEY SAID THEY DIDN’T CLEAR
IT PROPERLY THROUGH DHS.
THE FACTS OF THAT PRESS RELEASE
REMAIN THE FACTS.
IT WAS AN ACCURATE PRESS
RELEASE.
THEY UPSET THE DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT WANTS TO
CONTROL ALL PRESS.
YOU KNOW, THEY DON’T WANT THE
MEN AND WOMEN OF THE BORDER
PATROL THE CHIEFS OUT THERE
TALKING TO THE MEDIA.
THEY TONIGHT WANT THE TRUTH OUT
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO MUCH FOR A TRAPS PARENT
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE HIDING FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE CRISIS ON
THIS BORDER.
THAT IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
CRISIS.
MS-13 MEMBERS ARE COME THROUGH.
REAL QUICK, WHEN I WAS -- WE DID
OPERATION MATADOR IN PHOENIX YOU
MIGHT REMEMBER THAT COUPLE YEARS
AGO ARRESTED SHORT OF 500 GANG
MEMBERS, MINNESOTA MOST OF THEM
MS-13 MEMBERS.
42% OF THE GANG MEMBERS ARRESTED
CAME IN AS A UAC OR FAMILY
GROUP.
NOW TRY TO GET AROUND BORDER
PATROL 1,000 GOT AWAYSER DAY
BECAUSE THEY TIE THE BORDER
PATROL UP WITH FAMILIES.
ACTUALLY EMBEDDING THEMSELVES AS
UAC AND FAMILY GROUP.
THAT’S WHY YOU ARE HAVING FIGHTS
AT THESE FACILITIES.
THAT’S WHY YOU HAD A SEXUAL
ABUSE AT THESE FACILITIES.
THE GANGS AND CARTELS ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS AND CREATED A NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS FOR THIS COUNTRY
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
SIMPLY IGNORING.
AINSLEY: SO, A REPORTER DID ASK
JEN PSAKI ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS,
WHERE IS SHE?
WHY IS SHE TRAVELING AROUND THE
U.S. WHEN SHE IS IN CHARGE OF
THE BORDER AND SHE IS NOT DOWN
THERE?
LISTEN TO THIS.
IS SHE STILL WORKING ON THIS AND
CAN YOU ADDRESS THE PERCEPTION
THAT SHE IS KIND OF QUIETLY
BACKING OFF WHILE SECRETARY
MAYORKAS IS PURSUING SOME TRUMP
ERA POLICIES?
>> FIRST, I WOULD SAY THE VICE
PRESIDENT WAS VISITING CHICAGO
ACTUALLY TO TALK ABOUT COVID AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF COMMUNITIES
GETTING THE VACCINE WHEN IT’S
AVAILABLE AND ACCESSIBLE TO THEM
AND SO, WHILE SHE WAS THERE,
LIKE MANY AMERICANS, SHE GOT A
SNACK.
I THINK SHE IS ALLOWED TO DO
THAT.
IT IS AN ABSOLUTELY AN
ISSUE SHE REMAINS COMMITTED.
TO SAY THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
WHICH I’M SURE YOU ARE AWARE OF
IS NOT THE SAME AS THE BORDER.
AINSLEY: TOM, I KNOW YOU DON’T
WANT HER DOWN THERE AT THE
BORDER, WHEN YOU SEE ALL THESE
IMAGES OF THESE KIDS IT’S
PERSONAL TO YOU.
YOU HAVE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
YOU WORKED DOWN THERE FOR SO
LONG.
THIS IS A CRISIS WITHOUT A
DOUBT, AND IT’S INHUMANE.
>> IT’S ABSOLUTELY INHUMANE.
LOOK, I HAVE SAID IT MANY TIMES.
YOU SEE THESE VIDEOS OF A KID
BEING ABANDONED AND 9-YEAR-OLD
DROWNED THE OTHER DAY.
THERE IS A VIDEO YESTERDAY OF
THESE CHILDREN.
THAT HAPPENS EVERY DAY NUMEROUS
TIMES EVERY DAY ON THAT BORDER.
THESE BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE
DEALING WITH ABANDONED CHILDREN,
DYING CHILDREN, AND, LOOK, I
HAVE TOLD MY STORY MANY TIMES
HOW MANY TRAGEDY I HAVE SEEN ON
THE BORDER.
THAT’S WHY I’M ANGRY.
THIS CAN BE PREVENTED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD US ON THE
RIGHT ROAD.
70%, 80% DECLINE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION KILLED IN TWO WEEKS
BY THIS ADMINISTRATION.
BRIAN: TOM HOMAN, THANKS SO
MUCH.
THIS IS NOT GOING AWAY
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE VICE
PRESIDENT WAS ASKED TO HANDLE IT